in raising a question that I'm going to
be talking to you A lot of people
brought up this topic probably because
Eric Weinstein talked to Joe Rogan
recently and said that he and you were
contacted by folks about UFOs uh can you
clarify the nature of this contact
yeah yeah
I've got very little to say on this I
mean he has much more to say I think he
I think he went down
this Rabbit Hole further than than I did
um
which wouldn't surprise anyone
um he's got much more of a taste for
this sort of thing than I do but I think
we're contacted by the same person
it wasn't clear to me who this person
was or how this person got that my cell
phone number
um
they didn't seem
uh it didn't seem like we were getting
punked I mean the person seemed credible
to me
and then we're talking to you about the
release of different videos on you yeah
and this this is when there was a flurry
of activity around this so there was
like there was a big New Yorker article
on on UFOs and there was there was a
rumors of Congressional hearings I think
come in and
if and then with the the videos that uh
were being debunked or not
um
and so this person contacted both of us
I think around the same time and I think
he might have contacted Rogan or other
Eric is just the only person I've spoken
to about it I think
um who I know was contacted and
the um
what happened is the person kept you
know writing a check that he didn't cash
like he kept saying okay next week I'm
gonna you know I understand this is
sounding spooky and you know you have no
reason to really trust me but uh next
week I'm gonna I'm gonna put you on a
zoom call with people who you will
recognize and they're going to be you
know former heads of the CIA and you
know people people who just you're gonna
within five seconds of being on the zoom
call you'll you'll know this is not a
hoax uh so great just let me know just
send me the zoom link right and I went
that happened maybe three times you know
there was just one phone conversation
and then it was just texts you know
there's just a bunch of texts and I
think uh Eric spent more time with this
person and I'm not I haven't spoken
about I know he spoke about it publicly
but
um
so I you know it's not that my
detector ever
really went off in a big way is just the
thing never happened and I so I lost
interest so you made a comment which is
interesting that you ran the which I
really appreciate that you've ran the
thought experiment of saying okay maybe
we do have alien spacecraft or just the
thought of experiment the aliens did
visit yeah and then
this is very kind of nihilistic sad
thought that it wouldn't matter
it wouldn't affect your life can you can
you explain that well no I was I think
many people
noticed this I mean this was a sign of
how crazy the news cycle was at that
point right like we had coveted we had
Trump and I forget when this the UFO
thing was really kicking off but
uh it just seemed like no one had the
bandwidth to even be interested in this
it's like I I was amazed to
notice in myself
that I wasn't more interested in
figuring out what was going on it's like
and I I considered okay wait a minute
this is if this is true this is the
biggest story in anyone's lifetime I
mean contact with alien intelligence
is by definition the biggest story in
anyone's lifetime in in human history
um
why isn't this just
totally captivating and it Not only was
it not totally captivating it was just
barely rising to the level of
my being able to pay attention to it and
I I view that I mean one as a
um
to some degree a
an understandable defense mechanism
against the the
bogus claims that that have been made
about this kind of thing in the past
um
you know the general sense is probably
or it probably has some
explanation that just you know purely
terrestrial and not surprising and there
was there's there is somebody who
what's his name is Mick West I forget is
it a YouTuber yes yeah he debunked stuff
yeah he don't I mean I you know I I have
since seen some of those videos I mean
now now this is going back still at
least a year but some of those videos
seem like fairly credible debunkings of
some of the the optical evidence
um
and I'm surprised we haven't seen more
of that like there was a
a fairly credulous 60 Minutes piece that
came out around that time looking at
some of that video and it was the very
video that he was debunking on YouTube
and you know his his video only had like
50 000 views on it or whatever
um
but again it seemed like a fairly
credible debunking I haven't seen
debunkings of his debunkings but uh I
think there is but he's basically saying
that there is there is possible
explanations for it right and usually in
these kinds of contexts if there's a
possible explanation even if it seems
unlikely
is going to be more likely than an alien
civilization visiting us yeah it's the
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence principle which I
I think is generally true well with
aliens I think generally
I think there should be some humility
about what they would look like when
they show up but I tend to think they're
already here the amazing thing about
this AI conversation though is that
we're talking about a circumstance where
we would be designing the aliens yeah
and they would and there's every reason
to believe that eventually this is going
to happen like I said I'm not at all
skeptical about
the the coming reality of the aliens
that we're going to build them now
here's the thing does this apply to when
super intelligence shows up
will this be trending on Twitter for a
day and then we'll go on to complain
about
something Sam Harris once again said in
his podcast you you tend to trend on
Twitter even though you're not on
Twitter which is great yeah uh I don't I
haven't noticed I might I did I did
notice when I was on but um you have
this concern about
uh AGI basically same kind of thing that
we would just look the other way is
there something about this time where
even like world war three which has been
throwing around very casually
concerningly so even that the new cycle
wipes that away yeah well I I think we
have this
this General problem that we can't make
certain information even
you know
unequivocally certain information
emotionally
Salient like like we we respond quite
readily to certain things I mean as we
talked about we we respond to the
the little girl who fell down a well I
mean that just that gets 100 of our
emotional resources but
the abstract probability that of nuclear
war right even a high probability even
just even an intolerable probability
even if we put it at
30 percent right you know like it's just
like that's
a Russian roulette with a you know gun
with three chambers and you know it's
aimed at the heads not only your head
but your kid's head and everyone's kid's
head and it's just 24 hours a day and
um
I mean I think people who who this
pre-ukraine I think the people who have
made it their business to
you know professionally to think about
the risk of nuclear war and to mitigate
it you know people like Graham Allison
or William Perry or
I think they were putting like the the
ongoing risk I mean just the risk that
we're going to have if a proper nuclear
war at some point in the you know the
Next Generation
people were putting it at you know
something like 50 right they were living
with this sort of Damocles over our
heads now you might wonder whether
anyone could have reliable intuitions
about the probability of that kind of
thing but
the the status quo is truly alarming I
mean we've got you know we've got icbms
on Leaf aside smaller exchanges and you
know tactical nukes and how that could
how we could have a World War
you know based on you know incremental
changes we've got
the biggest bombs aimed at the biggest
cities in both directions
and it's old technology right and it's
you know and it's
vulnerable to some lunatic deciding to
launch or or misreading you know bad
data and we know we've been saved from
nuclear war
I think at least twice by
you know Soviet submarine commanders
deciding I'm not going to pass this up
to change Chain of Command right it's
like this is
almost certainly an error and it turns
out it wasn't error it's like like and
we we need people
to I mean in that particular case like
he saw I think it was five
what seemed like five missiles launched
from the US to Russia and he reasoned if
the if America was going to engage in a
first strike they'd launch more than
five missiles right so this this has to
be fictional and then he waited long
enough to decide that it was fictional
but the probability of
a nuclear war Happening by mistake or in
some other species of inadvertence you
know misunderstanding uh
technical malfunction
that's intolerable forget about the the
intentional use of it by by people who
are you know
Driven Crazy by some ideology
and more and more Technologies are
enable a kind of scale of Destruction
and misinformation plays into this
picture
in a way that is
especially scary I mean once you can get
a deep fake of
you know the any current president of
the United States claiming to have
launched a first strike you know and
just for you know send that everywhere
because I can change the nature of Truth
and then we that might change the
um the engine we have for skepticism
sharpen it
and digital watermarks that help us I
mean maybe we'll not trust any
information that hasn't come through
uh specific channels right I mean so
like in in my world
it's like
I I no longer feel the the need to resp
you know respond to anything other than
what I put out in in my channels of
information it's like there's there's so
much there's so many people who have
clipped stuff of me that shows the
opposite of what I was actually saying
in context I mean the people have like
re-edited my podcast audio to to make it
seem like I said the opposite of what I
was saying it's like unless I put it out
you know you can't be sure that I
actually said it you know I mean it's
it's just uh
but I don't know what it's like to live
like that for all forms of information
and uh I mean Strangely I think it may
require a
a greater siloin of information in the
end you know it's like it it it's uh
we're living through this sort of wild
west period where everyone's got a
newsletter and everyone's got a Blog and
everyone's got an opinion but once you
can fake everything there might be a
greater value for expertise yeah for
experts but a more rigorous system for
identifying who the experts are yeah or
just or just knowing that you know it's
going to be an arms race to
authenticate information so it's like if
if you can never trust a photograph
yeah unless it has been vetted by Getty
Images
because only Getty Images has the
resources to to authenticate the
provenance of that photograph and a test
that hasn't been meddled with by AI
um and again I don't even know if that's
technically possible and maybe whatever
the tools
available for this will be you know
commodified and and the cost will be
driven to zero so quickly that everyone
will be able to do it you know it could
be like encryption but and it would be
proven and tested most effectively first
of course as always in porn
yeah which is where most of human
innovation technology happens first